la neige c'est donc abattu surtout sur
la partie nord de nos départements
rendant donc les conditions de
circulation délicates voire difficiles
comme le montre cette carte établie par
le département du loir-et-cher
les opérations de déneigement ont débuté
tôt cette nuit
ce matin il restait encore des routes à
traiter lucas chopin était sur place à
blois
c'est un véritable ballet de camions qui
s'opère ce matin à blois 17 véhicules se
relaient sur les routes départementales
pour saler et déneiger la chaussée parmi
les conducteurs bruno sur le pied de
guerre depuis de longues heures
on tourne là depuis hier 15h45 pour
l'instant jusqu'à 8h ce matin et l'on
risque de repartir là dans les heures
qui arrivent par circuit ont fait
environ entre 3 tonnes et cape town de
sel ça dépend 1600 km de réseau loir et
chérien sont aujourd'hui prises en
charge par ces camions régulièrement
chargé en sel et en saumure une eau
salée si la neige est maîtrisé le froid
lui reste il est important donc d'être
vigilant les jours qui viennent
l'épisode froid devrait durer jusqu'à
dimanche prochain
donc c'est pas exclu que l'on fasse des
interventions régulières jusque là quoi
on est moins inquiet pour la neige parce
que les gens voient le phénomène est
donc fort naturellement attention on est
plus inquiet sur des phénomènes de
verglas ou de neige verglaçantes qui
sont encore pires ou la halle les les
gens peuvent être piégés parce qu'on
voit pas le verlan
météo france a levé l'alerté orange
neige sur le département mais des
températures descendant jusqu'à moins
sept degrés sont à nouveau attendus
demain